"Get to the microwave...
...in as few steps
as possible.
Open the door before
the microwave dings.
Fewest steps wins.
There are 5 minutes
on the clock.
The microwave starts now."
Where's the microwave?
[ Humming ]
Where's the micr-- Inside?
Have you seen
the microwave?
No.
-In the shed?
-Yeah.
Fewest steps?!
Damn it!
[ Cheering and applause ]
I structured the wording
in such a way that
there would be no possibility
of people just, you know,
taking steps.
No, and these are
clever people as well.
No one's just gonna
take big steps.
-[Laughing]
-No.
-Do you wanna see Dillon?
-Yes.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Ahhhhh!
♪♪
2, [laughing] 3,
[ Laughter ]
4, 5.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Maybe hopping's better?
♪♪
Uhh! 19, 20, 21, 22, 23.
26, 27, 28, 29.
[ Humming ]
[ Ding! ]
A potato.
Is that it?
Yeah, I mean, you got
here very quickly.
You thought about it
for...8 seconds,
which is longer
than usual.
[ Laughter ]
You're a dick.
[ Cheering and applause ]
You went with the big steps.
I have long legs, so,
why not use them?
You got there in 30 seconds
and you only took 29 steps,
so, I mean,
it's the lowest, so far.
-So far.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
We're gonna see
if somebody can come up
with a different way.
Shall we look at...
[ Laughter ]
Ron and Freddie?
Fewest steps wins.
Is this a step?
That's not really
a step, is it?
That's just crawling.
I'm gonna crawl it.
This doesn't count
as steps, right?
If you say so.
I feel like there are no steps
involved in this!
[ Laughter ]
[ Continues indistinctly ]
♪♪
Ron:
Not great for the knees,
I'll tell you that.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
That is not good,
but I gotta win.
♪♪
Audience: Ohhhhh!
Okay, that's worse.
[ Laughter ]
-You think you made it?
-I think, hopefully.
-Hi, Ron.
-Hi!
-How's your day going?
-So far, so good.
[ Humming ]
-[ Gasp ]
That's for me,
I'm afraid.
Just in time.
Hey!
Thanks, Ron.
Thank you!
Audience: Awww!
-That's quite hot, isn't it?
-Whahh!